وفي الاثناء نقل موقع بلومبيرج عن مسؤولين
غربيين قولهم ان الضربات الامريكيه
البريطانيه على الحوثيين في اليمن يبدو
انها قطعت خطوط الامداد الرئيسيه من ايران
الى جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن
مؤقت على الاقل لكنهم لفتوا الى انه لا
يزال من السابق لاوانه تقييم تاثير
الضربات على المدى
الطويل كذلك نقل الموقع عن مسؤولين
امريكيين وبريطانيين انه لم تحصل اي
محاوله لارسال شحنات عسكريه ايرانيه
للحوثيين منذ الحادي عشر من يناير كانون
الثاني الجاري وذلك عبر خطوط الامداد التي
ضربت والتي استخدمتها ايران لسنوات لنقل
الاسلحه الى الحوثيين عبر البحر الاحمر
وخليج عمان بما في ذلك عبر
الصومال وقال مسؤول لبلوم بيرج ان توقف
ارسال شحنات الاسلحه الاير يه للحوثيين
علامه ايجابيه ولكن طهران قد تستانف
جهودها لتسليح بينما افاد مسؤول اخر ان
الهدف الرئيس للضربات هو تدمير قدره
الحوثيين على اعاده تخزين الاسلحه بسرعه
رغم انهم يتلقون الاسلحه عبر طرق متعدده
بما في ذلك الطرق البريه كذلك نقل الموقع
ان بعض شركات تامين السفن بدات في تجنب
السفن التجاريه الامريكيه والبريطانيه ضد
مخاطر الحرب عندما تبحر في جنوب البحر
الاحمر